a minha infância ela é para ser contada
de acordo com a dura realidade que
várias crianças passou hoje de
trabalharem para levar o sustento para
suas famílias
aos seis anos eu cozinhava aos 9 anos
foi faxineira trabalhei numa banca de
jornal e aos 12 anos foi trabalhar na
casa onde minha mãe era empregada meu
patrão ele gostava muito das minhas
atitudes porque não tinha vergonha
nenhuma de ser empregada e ele me
perguntou você é batizada de odyssey não
com isso que me batizar fiquei muito
feliz porque ele tratava tanto a minha
mãe conta os outros funcionários muito
bem com dignidade
ele foi um anjo na minha vida e se hoje
eu estou aqui fazendo esse prédio x
pedra do sal
eu devo a ele minha mãe estava com
problemas renais começou hemodiálise se
depois do transplante
nós nunca tínhamos tido um contato tão
grande porque sempre quando os meus pais
se separaram eu ia com ele para quem não
ficar sozinho porque ele bebia muito mas
não trabalharmos juntas consegui sentir
seu carinho afeto amor mas por pouco
tempo
ela foi internada para nunca mais voltar
mas lembro-me bem como se fosse hoje
estávamos deitadas no chão do quarto de
empregada quando ela me disse pode pedir
uma coisa eu disse sim estúdio muito
seja alguém na vida
a educação é tudo na vida de uma pessoa
em disparada com isso você vai ficar boa
você vai voltar mas ela sabia que não
voltaria se foi mas deixou o objetivo
para mim o de estudar para ser alguém na
vida
hoje eu me questiono como é que uma
mulher que ela nem sabe escrever seu
nome dava tanta importância para a
educação
meu pai espanhol depois que minha mãe
morreu ele quis voltar para espanha e
fui com ele pois o paraíso queria
desenhar para mim para todos
ele não existia queriam que eu fosse a
que eu trabalhasse lá
mas eu pensava no que minha mãe tinha
falado eu pensava nos estudos e todas as
possibilidades que eu tinha no brasil e
falei pra ele gostaria de voltar e ele
deu uma resposta muito seca melhor você
retornar pois será uma boca - para
sustentar
naquele momento eu senti que estava
sozinha na vida e retornei terminei meu
curso técnico e fui trabalhar no
instituto militar de engenharia foi ser
técnica no padrinho me ajudou quando
imagina eu como técnicas subir uma
escada para poder trocar lâmpada
entrando longe vão os kits e entre os
andares que não conseguia ficar em pé se
tinha que andar a gastar em cheio de
morcegos para você passar fio trabalhava
com 14 homens somente eu quanto mulher e
sem muito bem as dificuldades né
ir de ser pioneiro em várias situações
mas isso a gente deixa para um próximo
ted x e winnie eu sempre quis mudar de
área
sair da manutenção e por uma área de
ensino mas adivinha como eu consegui de
uma faxineira que ela queria aprender a
ler
ela queria fazer um concurso público mas
ela não sabia ler e ofereci para
ensiná-lo e um dia estávamos depois do
horário está estudando e dizer assim
entrou um general porta dentro sem bater
e levei um susto ele deu boa noite e diz
e ela sem me dar chance disse maria está
me ensinando a ler ele a ler sim quero
fazer um concurso mas não sei ler
tempos depois eu fui transferida para a
área que eu queria só que sem pedir mas
sabe que foi melhor foi o agradecimento
dela minha rainha eu não passei mas você
foi mil óculos
o óculos de uma cega hoje eu consigo
andar na rua e saber o que está escrito
ai gente que quer coisa dizem que eu fiz
engenharia por ser estratégica muitos
homens
as mulheres que o rolê e aí eu saí
casadas têm que sair eu sou casada
o alexandre uma pessoa e é maravilhoso
estudioso inteligentíssimo a
cumplicidade ela faz parte das nossas
vidas
estudávamos juntos e sempre nos apoiamos
na alegria e na tristeza há 25 anos
para vocês terem uma noção ele passou
para fazer mestrado no ine
mas ele abriu mão por que os recebeu uma
oferta de emprego de uma uma
multinacional no mesmo dia para ganhar
quatro vezes mais do que eu
conversamos e chegamos a uma conclusão
ele trabalharia eu estudaria e depois
nós inverteriam a ele sempre né aí eu
fui assistir aula inaugural por ele
quando eu cheguei lá fiquei com muita
vontade de fazer o mestrado né e na
minha cabeça só vinha faça farsa vai ser
bom
pedi para ser o 20 deixado o grupo agora
é comigo né
no ano seguinte fiz a inscrição e foi a
primeira colocada o avanço do
crescimento foi tão grande que
paralelamente eu fiz uma pós graduação
vários cursos
iniciei o embi com tudo isso acontecendo
eu não poderia mais ficar no hino como
técnica mas a decisão de saída talvez se
tenha sido uma das mais difíceis
como é que eu ia deixar o serviço
público para ir para o mercado se
internada garantindo mais sair
a sensação foi como se eu tivesse dando
um salto no abismo
comecei com vários projetos e
consultoria dava aula na graduação e na
pós-graduação fgv me convidou para ser
uma das professoras do email dela
convidada no ibmec e andava as palestras
saía no jornal revista lançando livros
tudo perfeito tudo maravilhoso hora de
engravidar estava com 37 anos por fazer
os exames em fevereiro e no dia 14 de
julho e 2004
soube que eu estava com um linfoma
não hodkin é o que mata mas é o que cura
disse meu médico e meu mundo caiu
eu vou morrer mas eu nunca questionei
porque tudo isso estava acontecendo
comigo pois sou uma pessoa como outra
qualquer mas foi desafiador
um dia estava vomitando de sair lágrimas
dos meus olhos quando olhei para o
espelho careca fora de mim
perguntei senhor meu deus o que só quer
me dizer com isso
ufa cada quimioterapia tratava com menos
uma e não contava pra ninguém
nas últimas perguntei o meu médico tô
quais são as minhas chances de
engravidar
ele disse sair da menopausa 10%
engravidar 1
eu disse serei seu estudo de caso e fui
ver mas com 12 um casal com uma família
com a criança e dava uma inveja e no
mesmo momento pedia perdão a deus e que
abençoasse aquela família e 2005 uma
reunião geral da fundação getúlio vargas
disseram que premiará os dez melhores
professores de todos os ambientes estava
debilitada tinha feito a última
quimioterapia no dia anterior quando eu
escutei meu nome eles um susto como eu
o melhor pelo marido também recebeu o
prêmio são nove prêmios de melhor
professora e dentre os dez melhores
professores e sobre o quadro de honra da
fgv
tudo isso é em 2006 comecei sentindo
mais dores na barriga vômito passando
mal falei o câncer voltou
fui o médio pode evitar a prescrição da
tomografia eu disse pra ele do total
muito enjoada ele disse mesmo você não
tendo chances
eu vou fazer um teste de gravidez quando
eu peguei resultado eu vi que eu estava
grávida com grávida eu ia morrer e agora
vou dar à luz da morte à vida
escutar o coração da minha filha pela
primeira vez é algo que bate dentro de
mim até hoje nasceu a eduarda torre
como eu trabalhava muito sempre viajando
ela foi comigo até os 2 anos e 3 meses
as pessoas me criticavam mas eu queria
ficar com ela se referência dela com
tudo isso acontecendo teria que ficar
mais em casa e aí iniciamos alguns
negócios online
vamos atuar no mercado completamente
desconhecido onde a emoção bateu mais
forte
investimos muito dinheiro e muito
esforço mas não deu o resultado que nós
gostaríamos e decidimos recomeçar mas
recomeçar com significado forte de
transformar pessoas empresas e olhando
pra minha vida enquanto eu estava
fazendo e se ted x pedra do sal que
olhei disse
como pode ter dado certo o primeiro item
foi a educação
o segundo ter objetivos e quero falar
pra vocês três estratégias que o time
luso
a primeira eu penso positivo
não importa o que esteja acontecendo
comigo eu sempre venho a questão
positivo
eu penso sempre um dia nublado
onde eu sei que o sol está a ler mas não
está atrapalhando eu tenho certeza que
elas passaram e que esse sol iluminar
iluminar a outra questão é ter um
objetivo eu penso daqui a três anos
não sei se vocês têm mais é que há três
anos que vocês vão querer ler um jornal
uma revista num site de uma forma clara
eu leio esse meu futuro
outra que o meu cachorro sempre o que eu
fiz no último mês que eu agreguei valor
para minha vida
às vezes me pego não fazendo nada e aí
eu busco realmente fazer um diferencial
ter um diferencial competitivo e pra
falar pra vocês
a vida me trouxe muitos desafios e que
superei para hoje e tornar uma pessoa
consciente de que a educação eo otimismo
são elementos que transformam uma via
a minha trajetória e conecta com uma
missão e me lança a uma nova jornada
ajudar a criar um país melhor
por meio da educação será uma jornada e
tanto
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]